how did you celebrate with the family
it's so funny because my kids hardly
ever make it out to any of these award
shows because they last
way past their bedtime anytime i've ever
won an award it's amazing like when i
get home my kids are still awake and
right when i walked in the door
my kids like ran up to me and just gave
me a big hug and they said
congratulations daddy can i have a
popsicle
and so that's how celebration works
these days you know with three kids it's
like hey good for you but can i have
something too how has it been being home
with three little ones
under the age of five i can't even
imagine
it is absolute insanity all day
yeah i mean but at the same time it's
like
you wouldn't trade that insanity for the
world my wife and i snuck away down to
the beach for a weekend just us two
which is very needed you know if you
have kids you have to figure out time to
get away
the first night that we were at the
beach we we got in the bed and i looked
at her and i was like
you kind of miss our kids you know and
and it's like she's like yeah i do you
know because
you're around it so much and you're used
to being in a house where people are
screaming all day long
and asking for something and when you
actually get a chance to stop for a
second you're like dang what do we do
do you want more kids absolutely yeah oh
really yeah my wife has always wanted
five and
uh you know now that we're at three i've
got some friends that have gone from
three to four
and they're just like what's one more
you know what i'm saying like when
you're when you're already in the cave
it's just a little bit more chaos added
to it well today the country superstar
is welcoming a new musical baby it's the
first half of his fifth studio album
called country again
side and changed
this really is a journey of you being a
son
a father a husband what does it mean
to be country again things that i used
to put so much weight in
just don't hold the same weight anymore
and i looked right in front of me
and i was like i have the most amazing
wife and kids in the world
these are this is the priority you know
and when i started to
let that kind of lead my life
these songs just kind of fell out of me